ぅあ～あぁぁ～（欠伸）
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです 久しぶりにドンキに行ったんですけども
どれくらいぶりかな？
もう一か月ぶりくらいに行ったんですけども
ドンキのおもちゃコーナーが好きすぎて
いつも見ちゃうんですけども
今回はなかなか面白そうなロボットを見つけました
こちら
結構小さめのロボットなんですけども
なんかすごいんすよ
な、なんか
お”、おぼんとかで何かものを運んできたり
なんか、えっ、
なんだ…お前何してんの
音楽に合わせて何か踊ったり
。。。。。
んん？？？
完全に大暴走してますね
とりあえず開けてみましょう
要するに手の音とかに反応するロボットで
まあ　見ての通り
おぼんとコップがあるんで
ロボットが、こう、
自動で持ってきたりするんじゃないかなっていうね
気はしています
実際どうかわかんないけどね
バランス抜群
かわいい配膳ロボットって書いてあるから
おそらくなんか
ものを持ってきてくれるんじゃないかなっていう
とりあえず開けます
（開封）
チャンっ！
どーお”－これ大丈夫か
とりあえず電池！
単三３つです
はい、というわけで完成しました
さっそく動かしてみましょう
これ、説明書も何も入ってなかったから
情報量が著しく少ないんだよな
これ不可解すぎる
カチッ
どんな機能があるかもわかんないし
。。。。。。。。。。
…えっ？
電源ONにしたよ？
えっ　合ってるよね？
えっ　全部合っ…てまｓｓｓす……
ピロピロン♪
うわぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁぁ
（♪summerが流れ出す♪）
おれは
この曲を聞いた瞬間
あの夏を思い出した
（♪summerが流れ続ける♪）
ガチャン（ロボット落ちる）
おぉぉい！！！
ちょっと待ってー
急すぎるよいろいろと
待って待って
話聞いて！
まってー
話聞いて（２回目）
はなし…
なんで久石譲！？
ふっ…
まてまてまて！
曲のチョイスがすごい良いんですけど
まって！
音に反応。。。
パンパンパンパン（手をたたく）
まって！！
パンパン（手をたたく２回目）
まってまって
えぇ　何も聞かないじゃん！？
あんたあんたマジか！
ちょっと！！
パン×８（手をたたく３回目）
ちがーう！
おっ
パンパンパン（手をたたく４回目）
ガタン（ロボットまた落ちる）
（♪それでも鳴り続けるsummer♪）
ちょっといまいちわからんぞ
ねぇ　これどういうこと？
サウンドセンサーで自動に動く
光る　音楽が鳴る
そこは分かったんですけども
何か勝手に彼が
もう　久石譲の音楽で動いているだけで
僕は…
何も彼に干渉することはできません
音に反応するって書いてあるんですけど
完全に手拍子はしてるんで
何かしらで多分来るのかなって予想はしていますが
いまんとこ僕あれですからね
このロボット買って良かったこと
久石譲のsummer聞けるぐらいですからね
あーーーーー
あー　あっあー
あーあーあー（ロボットを呼ぶ）
まって　音、音こっち
音こっち
パンパンパン（手をたたく５回目）
ガタガタン（ロボットまた落ちる）
あーありがと
あの、もの運ぶときに
久石譲のsummerを、こう、
口ずさみながら来ると
接客としては決していい態度とは言えないので
あんまりサービスは良くないかなって気はしますね
この配膳ロボットは
こんなこともあろうかと
音で動くで
あろう
ロボットをたくさん買っておきました
ひとまず音楽が
久石譲のsummerだけかどうかっていうのを
なんか、みんな違う音楽かもしれないし
多分、GReeeeNのキセキとか
歌ってくれるやつもいるんだと思います
一回全員確かめてみましょう
何の音が鳴るか
口笛（summerを吹く）
ミュージックスタート
タン！
テレレレレレン♪
（♪summerがまた流れる♪）
お前も久石譲かいっ！
あーやばいな二人とも久石譲でしたねー
三人目！
えー
やーこれ、全員久石譲
ミュージックスタート
タン！
テレレレレレン♪
おぉぉぉぉぉぉぉ！！！
（♪summer♪）
（♪summer （キーどうした…？）♪）
カチッ
というわけで全部開けてみたんですけども
全員久石譲でした
とりあえずこの商品の謎を
1つ解きました
曲は全部統一して久石譲のsummerです
あとはホントねぇ
サウンドセンサーで自動で動くっていうのがわかんないなぁ
写真でも完全に手叩いてますから
手でたたくとどう反応するかがわかんない
近くまで来てくれるとも書いてないから
音に反応としか書いてないので
どのレベルで
どういう意味で
音が反応するのかがちょっと書いてないですね
もう意味が分かんないし
机だと落ちちゃうんで
地上で確認してみよう
パンパンパン（手をたたく６回目）
パンパンパン
パンパパパンパン
パンパパパンパパンパパンパン
。。。。。。。。。
（なんだよコイツ反応しねえじゃねえか…）
ぱぁぁぁぁぁ！
うわぁぁぁびっくりした
はぁ、ちょっと待って
なになになに
なるほどな
音に反応ってそういうことか
ひょっとして
音が止まってから
僕が何か話しかけると
また久石譲になるという
そういうことかもしれない　多分
パン
（♪summerが流れ出す♪）
はぁーなるほどねー
そういうことかわかった
音が鳴ると再び動き出すって意味の
音で反応という意味ですね
なるほどなるほど
OK OK 了解了解
パン
おーすごいな
なるほどなるほど
パン
すごい
（♪summerが同時に流れる♪）
よし
あぁー
まってまって
まって
バカーバカーバカ
バカバカバカ
ちょっと…
待って…
ねぇ
あぁぁぁぁ！！
ジャンジャカジャンジャカ（打楽器の音）